i don't often mention my my brother
jonathan who was killed
by al-qaeda affiliate in bali in 2002.
it prompted my personal interest in
afghanistan a distant country
i would visit a dozen times
over the last two decades to better
understand what we were doing to help
rebuild this troubled country and i paid
tribute to our armed forces to what they
did and what the defense secretary the
armed forces are doing today
in the evacuation
since without a disbelief seeing us make
such an operational a strategic blunder
by retreating
at this time a decision that's already
triggering a humanitarian disaster
a migrant crisis not seen since the
second world war
and a cultural change in rights to women
and once again
turning afghanistan into a breeding
ground for terrorism i'm sorry there's
no vote here today because i believe the
government would not have the support
of the house the prime minister's not in
his place
but he says the future of afghanistan is
not written
well the future is very much more
unpredictable because of our actions and
do not believe for a second that this
will be a peaceful transition to the
taivan it's not university like in the
country the uzbeks and tazzak's warlords
are regrouping as we speak the northern
alliance will reform once again and a
bloody terrible civil war will
unfold i will
does he have any advice for the
government on how it could take action
to try and prevent
uh the recurrence of a terrorist threat
under taliban control
well this is
my fear that there will be an attack on
the likes of 9 11 to bookend what
happened 20 years ago to show the
futility of 20 years we should never
have left and i'll come on to that in a
second because after 20 years of effort
this is a humiliating strategic defeat
for the west the taliban now control
more of the territory today than they
did before 9 11.
now i was born in the united states i'm
a proud dual national and passionate
about the transatlantic security
alliance
and prior to declaring his candidacy i
worked directly with the uh with
president biden on veterans mental
health issues he was the keynote speaker
at a veterans reception here in the
house of commons as my guest so it gives
me no joy
to criticize the president and say the
decision to withdraw which he inherited
but then chose to endorse was absolutely
the wrong call
yes two decades is a long time it's been
testing
chapter for afghanistan so the u.s
election promise to return troops was
obviously a popular one but it was a
false narrative
firstly the notion that we gave the
afghans every opportunity over 20 years
to progress and the country can't be
helped forever so it's time to come home
that glosses over the hurdles the own
goals that we created after the invasion
we denied the taliban a seat at the
table back in 2001.
they asked to attend the bomb talks but
donald rumsfeld said no
so they crossed to the pakistan border
to rearm and regroup and retrain how
different the last two decades would
have been
had they been
included
and secondly
the afghan forces themselves we didn't
start training the afghan forces until
2005 by which time the taliban were
already on the advance
and then finally we imposed a western
model of governance completely
inappropriate for afghanistan where all
the power was it was in kabul completely
wrong for a country where loyalty is on
a tribal and local level
this is not to dismiss the mass
corruption the criminalism and elitism
that is rife across afghanistan but
these schoolboy errors and stabilization
hampered progress and made our mission
harder
there's also the notion that we can't
fight a war
forever we've not been fighting for the
last three years
the us and the uk have not lost a single
soldier
but we had a minimalist force there
enough assistance to give the afghan
forces the ability to contain the
taliban and by extension legitimacy to
the afghan government the u.s had more
personnel
based in its embassy here than it had
troops in afghanistan before retreating
but both the u.s and the uk have
long-term commitments across the world
which we forget about japan germany
korea has already been mentioned
djibouti
niger jordan iraq ourselves in cyprus
and kenya for example the falklands too
it's the endurance that counts success
is not rated on when you return troops
home
this presence offers assurance
it represents commitment it bolsters
regional stability and it assists with
building and strengthening the armed
forces this is exactly what we were
doing in afghanistan
and last year the taliban were finally
at the negotiation table in doha but in
a rush to get a result
trump struck a deal with the tire
taliban by the way without the inclusion
of the afghan government
and committed a timetable for drawdown
and all the taliban had to do
was wait
and the final question about whether the
uk can lead or participate in a
coalition without the us
or where is our foreign policy
determined
here
or in washington
our government
should have more confidence in itself
very briefly i'm grateful to the
honourable member and he's making
perfectly reasonable and justified
criticisms of the way the american
government have come to the decision to
leave in in such haste
but like another a number of other
honorable and right honorable members
the implication of his speech is somehow
we could have had an independent afghan
policy without the americans can you
explain how
well firstly the americans are not
leaving afghanistan this is a complete
myth the cia will remain there as will
special forces and the drone oversight
as well why because they'll be haunted
by another terrorist attack it's the
political inclination it's the
leadership that is going disappearing
because of an american president or two
american presidents and that's where we
could have stepped forward and filled
the vacuum but we didn't
we should need to have more confidence
as a government in ourselves as we did
in fact in the last century illustrated
i thought this was what was in our dna
we have the means the hard power the
connections to lead
what we require is the backbone the
courage the leadership to step forward
yet when our moment comes such as this
we are found wanting we have some
serious questions to ask about our place
in the world what global britain really
means and what our foreign policy is all
about we must raise our game
why
step back we seem to be in denial about
where the world is going as i've said in
this house many times threats are
increasing
democracy across the globe globe is
under threat
authority terrorism is on the rise
and yet here we have we are complicit in
allowing another
dictatorship to form
as we become more isolationist
tell me what was the g7 summit all about
a western reset
to tackle growing instability not least
china russia and iran
take a look at the map where does
afghanistan sit
right between all three
strategically a useful country to stay
close to
now we've abandoned it
and the afghan people as well
shame
on us
i hope
the government thinks long and hard
about our place in a fast changing world
bigger challenges bigger threats loom
over the horizon
we are currently woefully unprepared and
uncommitted
we
the uk and the west have so many lessons
to be learned
i repeat my call for an independent
inquiry
we must learn these lessons quickly the
west is today a little more weaker and
the world a little more dangerous
because
we gave up on afghanistan